[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue dans votre
émission de débat en franche-comté je
suis ravi de vous retrouver pour une
nouvelle saison de dimanche en politique
avec ce matin une question centrale
comment limiter les effets néfastes des
pesticides comment protéger
l'environnement et les populations
rurales sont demander l'impossible à nos
agriculteurs on va en débattre avec nos
invités
je vous les présente tout de suite
d'abord jean pierre ok vous êtes maire
divers-droite demandeur dans le pays de
montbéliard et vous avez pris un arrêté
anti pesticides il y à quelques temps
vous nous expliquerez pourquoi également
sur ce plateau
un élu de la majorité christophe lejeune
député la république en marche de haute
saône
stéphane sauce vous êtes agriculteur à
nancray vous êtes éleveurs céréaliers
vous êtes aussi syndicaliste à la fdsea
en charge du dossier environnement à la
chambre d'agriculture du doubs et puis
enfin emmanuel mercier porte parole
bisontine du mouvement nous voulons des
coquelicots un mouvement qui milite pour
l'interdiction totale de tous les
pesticides de synthèse bonjour à tous
les quatre merci d'avoir accepté notre
invitation alors on reprend nos bonnes
habitudes cette émission c'est aussi la
vôtre vous pouvez l'a commentée sur les
réseaux sociaux avec le modeste qui
s'affiche dit mme paul fc comme dimanche
en politique franche comté et puis vous
pouvez interpeller nos invités leur
poser vos questions sur la page internet
de notre émission je me ferai d'ailleurs
le relais de certaines de ces questions
tout au long du débat alors madame
messieurs indésirables ou indispensable
pesticides voici ce qu'en disent
quelques francs comtois que nous avons
rencontrés au cours de nos reportages
ces dernières semaines extraits de
quelques journaux de france 3 franche
comté dans mon jardin est un
antibiotique dénommé 1
vous l'avez bressols aussi un il a
raison et leur réseau absolument tout le
monde devrait faire la même chose pour
on sait pas c'est la raison était
peut-être peut-être que oui peut-être
que non
les maladies causées par ces pesticides
c'est dangereux quoi pouvoir était ce à
quoi faut arrêter la culture intensive
et puis revenir d
d'habitude ancienne on va dire chapeau
de neige en hiver et tout mais ça normal
il faut arrêter ça tout ça parce que
nous les gens âgés mais les junies oui
ils ont tous plaidé monnerie j'ai vu
qu'il ya des limites de 2 m 2 5 m c'est
un peu ridicule c'est pas c'est pas de
mettre cinq mètres qui changeront que
sont beaucoup les choses ce qui changera
par contre c'est que la démarche de se
mettre ensemble autour d'une table qu'on
trouve un accord qu'on ne retrouve pas
eh bien elle est légitimée par l'état
elle a encouragé par l'état
nous on est prêt à faire un effort de de
faire une bande tampon 2 5 m mais il
faut que le riverain prenne à sa charge
une haie ou un mur là c'est donnant
donnant et puis parce que 150 mètres
vous rendez compte le préjudice
économique subi par expo temps qui va le
prendre en compte
[Musique]
voilà nous venons d'entendre
successivement les habitants de deux
communes où ont été pris des arrêtés
anti pesticides le maire de l'une
d'entre elles doivent sait est un
agriculteur de haute saône alors le
gouvernement vous l'avez compris a lancé
en début de semaine une consultation
nationale sur la distance minimale à
respecter entre les zones d'épandage et
les habitations l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire préconise 5 à 10
mètres selon les pesticides et selon les
cultures
christophe lejeune avec ce projet de
décret le gouvernement dit dit vouloir
protéger les riverains
faut-il considérer que dorénavant la
dangerosité des pesticides est actée au
plus haut niveau de l'état
écoutez ce n'est pas nouveau niveau de
la de la majorité ce discours nous
portons depuis un peu plus de deux ans
maintenant
nous leur ayons il n'est pas il est pas
il n'est pas nouveau simplement il doit
se faire dans la concertation
on ne peut pas faire comme si rien ne
s'était passé s'il n'y avait pas de
problème sanitaire
mais on ne peut pas oublier non plus nos
agriculteurs nous vivons essentiellement
dans un monde rural et c'est comme
l'agriculture qui est là pour nourrir
l'humanité et nos concitoyens en
particulier la france est un exemple le
lien savoir faire il ya déjà des
pratiques au niveau du bios au niveau de
l'agriculture raisonnée et raisonnable
par contre le périmètre immédiat des
habitations de préserver simplement
exemple j'ai été maire de bodo cours
communes rurales j'ai fait six ans 550
habitants 600 hectares la superficie de
la commune
j'ai pris j'ai fait le calcul avec la
carte communale
si on devait tracer cette bande des cent
cinquante mètres alors ses 160 hectares
qui serait de nouveau cultiver d'une
manière différente sur une commune de
600 ha voyez la proportion que ça
représente et il faut vraiment que ça se
fasse dans la concertation vous prenez
cet exemple ce chiffre des 150 mètres
parce que c'est ce que certains mais
repousse demande mais dites moi si on
considère au plus haut niveau de l'état
encore une fois que les pesticides sont
dangereux pour la santé humaine
pourquoi ne pas interdire purement et
simplement ses produits écoutez si nous
interdisons du jour au lendemain c'est
l'agriculture qui va tomber une grande
partie de l'agriculture va être à genoux
et c'est ce sera pire que tout au final
on sera obligé d'importer des aliments
qui viendront d'autres pays qui seront
moins vertueux que nous et ça c'est une
réalité
et finalement nous allons remettre d'une
alimentation qui viendra de produits
cultivés à base de pesticides emmanuel
merci et vous le mouvement des
coquelicots vous prenez l'interdiction
totale de tous les pesticides de
synthèse qu'est ce que vous dites
aujourd'hui au gouvernement
bravo c'est un premier pas encourageant
un premier pas seulement mais un premier
pas encourageant ou vous dit attention
vous n'allait vraiment pas assez loin
alors on prône l'interdiction de tous
les pesticides en ayant bien évidemment
conscience qu'il ya besoin d'une
transition et les choses peuvent pas se
faire du jour au lendemain on n'est pas
un naïf
par contre dire qu'aujourd'hui il ya un
pas en avant non parce que en 2007 le
grenelle de l'environnement et le plan
ecophyto avait déjà établi la
dangerosité des pesticides et la
nécessité de diminuer leur utilisation
on avait comme objectif de les baisser
de 50% en 10 ans en 2017 l'utilisation
des pesticides avait été augmenté de 20%
donc aujourd'hui l'heure n'est pas à
dire et en 2007 on était sous le
gouvernement de monsieur sarkozy
donc aujourd'hui monsieur mac rang et
son gouvernement ne peuvent pas nous
dire on vient de réaliser la dangerosité
on va protéger nos populations la
dangerosité elle est établie depuis
longtemps elle est reconnue maintenant
la question et l'accompagnement
la transition jean-pierre ok vous faites
partie des quatre maires du département
du doubs avoir pris des arrêtés limitant
ou interdisant les pesticides
la nuance est importante notamment pour
votre commune d'y expliquer ce que vous
pouvez nous expliquer pourquoi avoir
pris cette décision à mandeure dans le
pays de montbéliard
la raison première est était déjà une
plainte de riverains que j'ai
enregistrée en 2010 huit plaintes que je
n'ai pas on va dire poursuivi parce que
je n'avais pas suffisamment d'éléments
pour la traiter et d'éléments à la fois
juridique et puis d'éléments pour dire à
un agriculteur non peu plus détaillée en
soyons clairs sont des habitants de
votre commune qui sont venus vous voir
en disant l'agriculteur qu'a le champ à
côté de chez moi
ils nous envoient des pesticides dans
les murs et ça c'est exactement ça
exactement ça donc j'ai attendu quand
même d'avoir examiner tous les dossiers
avoir des éléments probants pour pouvoir
lancer n'arrêtait pas ce que vous
prendre un arrêté on ne fait pas comme
ça le fait pas ce pour ce faire annuler
on fait pour que ça serve à quelque
chose donc l'arrêter je n'ai pas pris
tout de suite je les prie long juillet
de cette année tout simplement parce que
il y avait une association de bretagne
qui en 2017 avait attaqué devant le
conseil d'état l'arrêté du 4 mai
2010cette concernant les pesticides et
leurs modes d'épandage et j'ai préféré
attendre que le conseil d'état se
prononce pour l'enseignement d'arrêter
et vous votre arrêté les spécifique
c'est-à-dire que vous n'interdisez pas à
l' usage des pesticides
vous préconisez une zone tampon de 20
mètres mais qui est tout à fait
indicative on sait très bien que
bon c'est vrai que la spécificité et la
spécificité de la commune fait qu on a
très peu de zones agricoles très proche
des habitations
cette habitation là est vraiment au
droit voilà c'est tout y'a pas disons
que pour la commune ça ne va pas
apporter une perte énorme mais pour moi
la limite c'est pas ça je pense que pour
ce qui concerne les pesticides
l'intérêt c'est que 1 on puisse les
répandre parce que on en a besoin c'est
très bien comme disait madame on sait
très bien qu'on va pas changer du jour
au delà la situation que les
agriculteurs ont une nécessité de les
utiliser et qu' il faudra un certain
temps pour ne plus s'en servir
justement on va se tourner vers
l'agriculteur sur ce plateau bonjour
stéphane sauce comment et la profession
vit cette période où on a l'impression
que vous êtes stigmatisé en tout cas des
produits que vous utilisez tous les
jours ou presque sont systématiquement
mises en cause bah déjà c'est un plaisir
déjà de pouvoir intervenir ce matin dans
l'émission et puis de pouvoir être être
entouré de personnes voilà qu'on est con
on est con des visions différentes par
rapport à ce sujet là c'est vrai que en
premier lieu moi je pense qu'il faut
quand même déjà tout de suite
moi j'ai envie de dire aux agriculteurs
quoi qu'il faut pas non plus qu'ils
perdent est ce pas parce que c'est vrai
que des fois on a l'impression où on
entend cette semaine c'est des trois
dernières semaines
comme quoi on est bien on est un petit
peu le les pires du monde dans ce monde
est que l'agriculture il faut absolument
tout arrêter donc avec moi j'ai envie de
dire aux jeunes qu'ils sont rentrés l'un
dans les écoles ya pas longtemps qu'ils
sont en train de se former parce que
pour être agriculteur pour pouvoir
utiliser des produits il faut savoir il
faut se former et on se forme aussi tout
au long de sa vie il faut continuer il
faut pas avoir peur comme on l'a dit il
faut prendre le sujet non pas un sujet
rétréci mais il faut lever le nez
regarder un peu plus loin sa commune
département je pense
la france l'europe le monde on aime ça
dans un monde
il faut absolument qu'on en prenne
considération aussi il faut pas qu'on
reste des petits gaulois comme le fan le
débat français pour le coup sûr la bande
tampon 5
6 20 m ça vous paraît des compromis
acceptables pour les agriculteurs
d'après moi ce qui me choque et même
aujourd'hui en fait ce que j'ai envie de
dire c'est que je me dise ce qu'il
manque aux quand même autour de la table
la recherche c'est qu'elle est la
recherche aujourd'hui parce que moi je
peux dire ou demain on se met à un mètre
du maison on peut lancer des chiffres
comme ça qu'ils veulent rien dire et
tout dire en fait on balance les
chiffres et l'ont dit mais oui mais oui
je sais la vérité c'est 20 mètres moi
j'étais en vérité ces 5 c et 10 c 150
moi je dis peut-être qu'il faut à faire
intervenir aussi la recherche moi je
regardais de l' agence nationale de
sécurité sanitaire a pris position ces 5
ou 10 mètres selon les cultures et
notamment la hauteur des cultures et
selon le type de pesticides donc les
chercheurs notamment les agences
françaises se positionne là dessus voilà
mes 2 sur 5 ou 10 mètres
moi je pense qu'il dirait c'est un
premier point c'est qu'il faut quand
même le prendre en considération et que
les communes aussi doivent l'entendre en
disant pas écouté voilà la recherche a
déjà ses positionner là dessus mais la
recherche n'est pas que là dessus parce
que on à l'inra à dijon où c'est que
nous agriculteurs et chambre
d'agriculture on essaye justement
d'avoir des ponts qui soit fait entre la
recherche et le monde agricole
hum ça fait 20 ans qu'ils travaillent
sur des champs sans pesticides par
exemple ça marche ça ici on y arrive on
arrive à avancer mais encore une fois ça
se fait pas en claquant des doigts
et encore une fois du coup il faut aussi
comment prendre on va dire
toute la diversité qui peut y avoir dans
le monde agricole de l'adversité qu'on
peut avoir dans les constructions de ces
aujourd'hui est-ce que c'est pas le
principe de précaution et la santé
publique avant tout christophe lejeune
écoutez le prêt la santé publique
ça c'est une nécessité absolue le
principe de précaution il faut
l'appliquer à bon escient été mis en
avant par les eu de nombreux maires il
ya plusieurs dizaine d'arrêtés
municipaux qui ont été pris tout à fait
mais il ya aussi des arrêtés municipaux
qui ont été pris dans des communes où il
ya absolument pas d'agriculteurs donc
c'est aussi pour eux permettre de faire
avancer le débat
mais il faut pas non plus généraliser la
position par contre pour moi la
concertation elle est obligatoire parce
que le monde agricole
il faut qu'il soit autour de la table
parce que c'était un acteur essentiel et
on doit absolument pas de stigmatiser
les maires ruraux et je me répète j'en
étais j'ai été maire d'une commune
rurale
on doit être aussi au tour de table par
contre on a le volet agricole de
préserver et aussi de préserver nos
concitoyens mais aussi l'urbanisation de
nos communes il va falloir aussi que les
maires prennent conscience que les
lotissements en dehors des communes
il va plus falloir les cris d'une
manière systématique il va falloir
penser à revitaliser les centre du
village
parce qu'à chaque fois qu'on va faire un
lotissement à l'extérieur on va se
mettre de facto avec des nouveaux
habitants face à des terrains agricoles
je reviens au travail est vrai ça et
c'est ce que disent d'ailleurs beaucoup
d'agriculteurs ils disent en fait les
maisons sont venus au milieu des champs
oui la campagne a beaucoup changé
seul humain mais justement avec l'épée
élus qui sont pris dans locaux
d'urbanisme locaux d'urbanisme eh bien
on a une grande préservation des du
domaine agricole
donc les lotissements n'iront plus vers
les paie les terrains agricoles
mais comme vous disiez l'art vide et la
revitalisation des centres bourgs est
avait est importante parce qu'on a des
dents creuses comme on appelle ça
d'urbanisme on a des dents creuses qu'il
va falloir combler c'est là qu'ils
veulent que tout l'effort doit se porter
non pas vers l'extérieur de la commune
mais recentrer un petit peu la commune
pour ne pas l'étendre de trop et gagner
sur des terrains agricoles qui peuvent
être exploitées et limiter ainsi les
problèmes
une réaction d'un internaute julien qui
nous dit le souci c'est le cocktail de
produits phytosanitaires
c'est toute l'agriculture industrielle
qui doit se réformer en interdisant la
chimie dans les champs comment vous
recevez ce type de message on le reçoit
tellement souvent à force que du coup ça
commence un petit peu a glissé et le
problème dans sa c'est que s excuse moi
mais est ce que là on parle de protéger
les riverains c'est que jean le lien le
voilà mais vous vous êtes utilisateur
est ce que vous vous sentez en danger
vous en tant qu'utilisateur est ce que
vous sentez protéger moi enfin le seul
moment je trouve que c'est dangereux les
produits phytosanitaires c'est quand on
l'utilisé c'est à dire que quand on
prend le bidon et c'est là où c'est
qu'on va remplir notre pu lever le seul
moment aussi que le produit phyto il est
à 100% c'est à ce moment-là cantonales
bidon et qu'on va remplir et pu lever
même si aujourd'hui du coup les pu lui
sont faits pour en arriver à ne pas
avoir de d'éclat qui viennent sur soi et
ainsi de suite après l'utilisation d'un
produit chimique
c'est pas un litre de deux fils tombé
dans un champ c'est un livre de filter
qu'on peut mettre qu'on dilue à 100 150
litres qu'on dépend le matin bien
souvent qu'on est con avec quino trimé
dur mais très forte
donc en fait c'est tout ça et donc voila
moi le ce qu'est ce qui fait peur en
fait sur ces sujets là c'est que tout le
monde a un avis c'est comme sur d'autres
sujets qu'on peut entendre là en ce
moment en plein débat qui peuvent se
faire sur d'autres
tout le monde a un avis tout le monde
est sûre de son avis tout le monde est
sûr de ces chiffres et du coup la
concertation du coup j'ai pas très du
coût des fois il tourne un petit peu en
rond parce que du coup on a vu une
personne ne veut bouger sur ses
préoccupations alors le mouvement des
coquelicots
j'aimerais réagir déjà par rapport à
votre première intervention sur
effectivement le clivage qui est en
train de monter dans la société entre
des citoyens qui pour demander
protection serait en train d'accuser des
agriculteurs qui deviendraient des
empoisonneurs et on sentait une pression
comme ça je pense qui est totalement
injuste et le mouvement des coquelicots
la ferme aux efforts on veut des
coquelicots mais on veut aussi dépaysant
et il n'y a absolument pas de
confrontation à avoir entre victimes d
pesticides que son et les agriculteurs
et les consommateurs et les agriculteurs
y mange aussi donc au même titre que
nous tous
et d'ailleurs nous tous autour de cette
table on est on est potentiellement
effectivement victimes des pesticides
moi j'aimerais dire que c'est vraiment
d'ailleurs vous entendez la demande des
agriculteurs qui disent nous faut du
temps pour changer alors le temps
évidemment mais c'est ce que je disais
tout à l'heure c'est à dire que la
dénonciation de la dangerosité des
produits
elle ne date pas d'hier elle ne date pas
ni de la prise de conscience de monsieur
macron cet été ni elle date de ya fort
longtemps l'interdiction des produits se
fait en cascade depuis 40 ans un produit
est interdite un autre le remplace donc
la dangerosité au fil de l'eau et de son
établissement bien finalement elle ne
donne rien puisque on la remplace par un
autre produit il ya un vrai problème
auquel on est tous confrontés et je
pense moi j'ai lu un article qui m'a
vraiment touché d'une agricultrice dans
le figaro qui est paru fin août dans le
figaro et d'une agricultrice qui au
moment de la signature du ceta a dit
elle était visiblement en train de
travailler et elle a dit mais moi je
m'écroule j'ai l'impression d'être
enfermé entre quatre murs
le premier mur il est versé la pression
sociale écologique et on nous stigmatise
et ça devient un métier très difficile à
exercer le deuxième mur il est blanc
c'est celui de tous ces traités
internationaux où il ya une telle
pression sur la productivité qu'on peut
pas sortir des intrants chimiques pour
répondre à ces exigences là le troisième
muridés rouge c'est celui de la viande
c'est celui de la condition animale
c'est celui des éleveurs dont vous êtes
monsieur puisque on en parlait tout à
l'heure et où il ya une vraie pression
sur le bien-être animal et ça devient
aussi un métier très difficile à exercer
celui des éleveurs et le troisième le
quatrième il est noir c'est celui du
désespoir des agriculteurs
un agriculteur par jour se suicide en
france
la souffrance au travail des
agriculteurs c'est un problème
fondamental le mouvement des coquelicots
il est pas là pour aller tirer sur les
agriculteurs vous êtes souvent pointé du
lendemain oui les coquelicots c'est que
les gens qui habitent en ville
est ce qu'il n'ya pas deux mondes qui
sont en train de s'éloigner finalement
j'espère que non j'espère vraiment que
non la question même de l'autonomie
alimentaire des villes c'est un vrai
sujet dont je pense qu'il y aurait à
imaginer ans
parler d'aménagement du territoire des
maisons qui se construisent dans les
champs mais si on veut au delà même la
question des pesticides
regardez un peu en face les enjeux
environnementaux aujourd'hui je pense
qu'il va falloir cultivées en ville
recultivée en ville donc j'espère que
c'est pas un problème de bobos urbains
effectivement comme on peut nous le
reprocher on a tous dans nos assiettes à
manger du bio du pas bio en a pas mais
le premier me concerne tout le monde et
les pesticides alors juste une toute
petite remarque sur la question de la
distance les pesticides ils sont
volatiles ils sont dans l'air et sont
dans l'eau alors effectivement quand ils
sont purs et que les agriculteurs sont
obligés se protègent de les épandre
heureusement pour eux qu'ils se
protègent mais nous on a mené à besançon
la campagne de dosage du glyphosate dans
les urines tout le monde des taux
supérieurs à ceux qui sont tolérés dans
l'eau tout le monde que vous habitiez en
ville à la campagne que vous mangez bio
pas bio donc on est tous contaminés
c'est un problème qui nous concerne tous
jean pierre roquet est ce que certains
maires alors je sais pas si vous
considérez parmi ceux-là mais qui ont
pris des arrêtés se considèrent comme
des lanceurs d'alerté disent ok on va se
faire très certainement retoqué devant
les tribunaux administratifs y avait une
audience encore vendredi
l'aga avant-hier pour deux de vos
collègues du doubs mais on se positionne
pour faire évoluer la loi est ce qu'il
ya ce cette idée là cette idée
directrice la dent dans vos dans la
démarche de des mères qui prennent des
arrêtés anti pesticides dans la démarche
du maire je ne veux pas anticiper parce
que je ne les connais pas tous mais en
ce qui concerne
en ce qui me concerne c'est plus facile
pour moi pour moi c'est plus une prise
de conscience parce qu'à un moment donné
il faut quand même que on sait bien que
la police spéciale de l'état le maire
n'a pas y mettre les pieds sauf
exception mais on est on est quand même
confronté à la santé des citoyens
on a dans notre pays général le la
nécessité de protéger et de la sécurité
des citoyens
donc à un moment donné oui si les textes
d'état ne sont pas suffisants
sont incomplets c'est ce qui s'est passé
avec le conseil d'état puisqu'il a non
pas retoqué le l'arrêté du 4 mai 2010 et
mais il a simplement demandé à l'état
dans les six mois de modifier certains
articles de cet arrêté
eh bien oui que l'état fasse le
nécessaire et qu'il prenne en compte
dans ces arrêtés
la santé des du public et non pas la
sauter de certains groupes fragile une
réaction cette semaine de jérémy 2 clc1
nos voisins il est bourguignon il est
député européen la république ans c'est
l'ancien président national des jeunes
agriculteurs et disait que rend le débat
sur les pesticides et irrationnel les
écolos des villes décourage les paysans
deschamps ils remettent en cause le
professionnalisme des agriculteurs ils
sont incapables de prendre en
considération les évolutions de
l'agriculture française dites-moi est-ce
que à la campagne cohabitent aujourd'hui
demande irréconciliables christophe
lejeune je ne le pense pas et surtout il
ne faudrait pas que qu'on puisse laisser
cette cette impression il y a toujours
eu des problèmes de voisinage
chaque maire a eu des dons dans
l'exercice de son mandat à gérer des
problèmes de voisinage
là c'est un nouveau problème de
voisinage qui est qui est évoqué mais il
doit être traité comme il a toujours été
traités et je voulais revenir quand
est-ce que c'est irrationnel est ce que
vous êtes d'accord avec votre collègue
député européen est-ce qu'on est sur un
débat quelqu'un qui peut être très
inflammables parce qu'on touche à la
santé publique
alors qu on touche à la santé publique
c'est vrai par contre ce qui est
irrationnel peut-être c'est de laisser
croire que l'agriculture dans
l'utilisation de produits chimiques n'a
pas n'a pas évolué depuis vingt ou
trente ans on sait très bien que il y à
des progrès qui ont été faits dans la
dangerosité des produits dans la latence
it et de l'utilisation des produits
mais la société civile ou en aucun cas
une partie d'entre elle est impatiente
voilà elle est impatient demande que ça
aille plus vite elle est impatiente
inquiète mais mais pour autant il ne
faut pas je vous dis c'est ce que je
disais en début de matinée
c'est que si on met la pression et qu'on
va trop vite on risque de faire tous
tombés
c'est en ça que notre rôle il doit être
de chaque côté on doit être modérée on
doit surtout pas refermer ce dossier
on doit le faire avancer de manière
concertée mais la pire des choses ce
serait d'arrêter de se parler et que
effectivement ça devienne irrationnel il
faut il faut stopper ce cet incendie qui
pourrait couvent et une réaction des
indices quand il n'y aura plus assez de
production en france parce que les bobos
des colonies connaissent rien et or ont
voulu l'arrêt complet des pesticides
on devra importer des autres pays qui
utilisent des ogm et des pesticides
interdits en france depuis des années
les gens sont cohérents stéphane source
ben c'est ce qu'ont déjà c'est ce qu'on
fait aujourd'hui la france était une
force agricole aujourd'hui petit à petit
on voit qu'on importe bientôt plus que
ce qu'on exporte quoi est-ce que la
france de devenir un exportateur au
niveau européen je sais pas mais ce que
la france 2 déjà arrivé à se nourrir je
pense que c'est important
donc à mon avis et on ne peut pas y
arriver qu'avec du bio parce que ce
qu'on va vous rétorquez c'est que les
producteurs bio il y arrive
oui mais c'est justement en fait je
pense que c'est pas blanc ou noir en
fait il faut arrêter de toujours qu'on
sait qu'il ya un côté des gens qui font
bien et de l'autre des gens qui font pas
bien à mon avis la france et
l'agriculture et fort de sa diversité a
bien ou mal fait le yari vais sans
pesticides la clé moi je sais je réponse
la recherche
il faut du temps j'ai dit aujourd'hui on
ne fait pas ce conseil à 20 ans et on y
est il ya 20 ans vous êtes pas conscient
qu'il ya vingt ans mon grand père on
utilise déjà des produits chimiques
c'est pas ça date pas d'hier des
produits chimiques près d'elle et les
gens sont encore ici aujourd'hui un
quand même malgré l'utilisation de
produits chimiques et 60 ans à tous mais
je veux dire aujourd'hui ça a évolué on
a travaillé on fait différemment
maintenant on va traiter très très tôt
le matin coincé mais on se rend même pas
compte aujourd'hui parce que du coup on
dit c'est normal aussi comme on aurait
comment on a pu faire ça avant mais
aujourd'hui pour nous ça nous paraît
logique cette évolution ou là vous vous
dites comment on aurait pu faire ça
avant peut-être que dans 20 ans on se
dira mais comment on a pu appauvrir les
sols comment les appauvrit polluer l'eau
comme on pollue l'eau et effectivement
il ya la protection des habitants mais
il ya la protection de la nature
et là on est dans une situation où
l'appauvrissement des sols il va devenir
réellement problématique pour la
productivité et les objectifs que vous
êtes en train de vous fixer nous
l'analyse qu'on fait on parle vous
parliez tout à l'heure de
l'irrationalité il ya de la colère il ya
de l'inquiétude dont il ya de l'émotion
forcément il ya des motions on ne peut
pas être que dans un discours purement
rationnel dans lequel ma foi autour de
la table très tranquillement prendrait
le temps d'une transition
ça fait des années des années que les
alertes sont sonnés là aujourd'hui je
pense quand même c'est la raison en tout
cas moi de mon engagement que la
mobilisation des citoyens
moi mon engagement il a fait suite à la
démission nicolas hulot c'est ça qui m'a
complètement bouleversé je me suis dit
mais en fait les politiques
aujourd'hui ils n'ont plus les moyens
d'agir donc les bras laurent tombe à eux
mêmes les plus sincères et puis ici
alors quand on voit des mers poser des
arrêtés comme ce qu'on voit là
effectivement ça redonne espoir moi
sincèrement je vais vous dire que
l'échelle locale s'est laissé les châles
auquel je retrouve espoir au niveau du
pouvoir politique et du courage
politique
oui c'est pile poil le message en fait
qui est mauvais en fait aujourd'hui à
mettre dans les débats télévisés
c'est pile ce message là c'est à dire
vous avez culteurs vous pouvez vous
polluer les sols vous polluer l'eau et à
cause de vous on rira tout ça non enfin
il faut arrêter un produit agriculteurs
on lui a demandé de produire
on a produit avec certainement des fois
des produits vous c'est que du coup la
dangerosité est arrivé après mais on n'a
pas polluer les sols aussi tout poli les
soldes aujourd'hui tout ce qu'on peut
mettre nous sur nos corps polluent les
sols tout ce qu'on peut avaler comme
médicament polluent les sols les
agriculteurs ne sont pas des pollueurs
de sol faut faut arrêter avec ça parce
que justement comme vous le dites ici en
fait tout le monde reprend ça en disant
regardez vous a plu non non non non non
non non non les seuls sont moins bons
qu'avant mais moi je fais des analyses
tous les jours enfin on fait des avis
tous les temps de nous cela je sais pas
d'où sort cette cette mode de dire que
les soldes sont plus beau vraiment je ne
vois pas où pourra malheureusement il
s'en sort très bien
ben non mais il faut arrêter de penser
qu' une personne qui va sortir un
contrat en disant tiens le soleil parce
qu'avant on faisait pas d'alice deux
seuls comment on peut nous dire
qu'aujourd'hui les sols sont plus
pauvres qu'avant alors comment vous et
bonne analyse
ça c'est le même discours je vais vous
arrêter c'est la fin de l'émission pile
on aurait pu faire une heure de plus je
pense merci à tous les quatre dans un
instant le flash d'information avec
florence s'y colle heures puis la suite
de dimension politique bonne après midi
pique
[Musique]